we're going to go back to uh Moscow for
uh we've got some more pictures of uh
here is Evan gershkovich The Wall Street
Journal correspondent arrested on the
charges of spying by the Russians we can
speak now to our correspondent uh John
Sparks uh John obviously this is the
first time we've seen Evan gershkovic
since he was arrested
that's right yeah he is the I mean the
significance of this is that he is the
first American the First Western
journalist I believe to have been
arrested by the Russian authorities
since the cold war that is the the
significance of this
um the case today is around his
detention his pre-trial detention and we
can see him here in the in the Dock of
the courtroom he looks relatively
relaxed we'll be speaking to his lawyers
there but this is not about the the
substance of his charges that will come
later at the moment this is about how he
is being detained at the moment he's
currently being held in custody at the a
prison just outside of Moscow called le
tovo le fertovo it's a notorious prison
in Russia where traditionally political
prisoners have been kept he has been
charged with Espionage or spying he
faces up to 20 years in prison if he is
found guilty and what the Russians say
is that he was caught red-handed trying
to obtain classified material about an
arms Factory in yakaterenburg that's a
large city in Siberia almost 2 000
kilometers to the east of Moscow and he
was arrested on the 30th of March the
last time the newspaper that he works
for works for the Wall Street Journal
heard from him was just as he was about
to enter a steak restaurant weren't able
to get in touch with him anymore there
we can see him again he's in the dock
this will be before the case before the
hearing that he is about to appear in he
will be trying
to
I would assume his lawyers will be
trying to get an alternative custody
arrangement for him he is being held at
the moment in a prison called leffortovo
just outside of Moscow the Americans
have been struggling to get access to
him the U.S ambassador yesterday was
able to see him and said that he was
holding up his his spirits were were
strong and the U.S President Joe Biden
he has talked about this case as well he
has called
the uh the Detention of gershkovic as
totally illegal and the state department
the the foreign Ministry of the U.S
government they say he has been
wrongfully detained at the charges of
bogus and that the case is political and
it is possible that the Russians are
thinking longer term around a a prisoner
swap that has happened in the past back
in December they swapped an American
basketball player called Brittany
Greiner who had been convicted on drugs
charges they swapped her for a notorious
arms trafficker called Victor boot it
was held by the Americans they did that
swap back in December that could be part
of the thinking here
but at the moment uh gershkovic trying
to he's trying to get alternative
detention Arrangements at the moment
this is not about the substance of those
charges I I think that he is he is
looking realistically he's looking at
spending a a long term a significant
period of time in in a Russian prison at
the moment
the woman in the uh center of the
picture now in blue that is Lynn Tracy
she is the U.S ambassador to Moscow I
mean it's pretty significant that she's
actually there in the courtroom isn't it
yes yes it is uh it is significant she
did have the opportunity to to see him
she was able to gain access to the
prison yesterday and she was able to
report that uh gershkovic was in was in
good spirits and grishkovic has also
been able to write to his parents uh he
said he's been eating properly he's been
able to get some exercise he's also
writing as well again you know this is
it's significant because it's so rare he
is a journalist for an established
newspaper The Wall Street Journal they
have Bureau all over the world he was
hired just before the invasion of
Ukraine began prior to that he'd been
working to an English language
publication in Moscow the Moscow times
he's an experienced journalist he speaks
Russian so he would have been aware of
some of the risks and dangers of working
in Russia but obviously significant
concerns now both for his family for the
U.S government as well who who see him
as a political prisoner